今日は2月14バレンタインでの今
1時45前です
ちょうど今起きましたねねぇ
ハッピーバレンタインあっぴーばれんたいんぱっぴーばれんたいなんだけど今起きまし
た
何を書く側連打委員はね
僕の誕生日なんですよ
it 理由
なんとかに付い生になりましたありがとうございます
午前中は誰とも話さずずっとベッドで寝て思ったんですけど
大変な動画王日間で誕生日
僕の誕生日1日3つだけ童話みたいな[ __ ]はちょっと
しようと思います祭髪が4階の柱はでもカメラ持って一日ある組んでイギリスも
ちょっとこうみんなに見えると思うんでっ
あぜひよかったら僕の鍛造リー
よってください
外はなぁあんまり天気良くないんだよな
ビジネス今洪水がすごくて
ん
ハメっつー
から壊れそういつもこのルートで学校に行ってるんですよ
いやほんとも持っての dj ダケが終わるから
ん
ちょっと一歩一歩踏みしめた糸を吸ってん
とりあえず今バス停に向かって
バス人がとって重心の街の方に行ってパッソご飯を食べます
まぁきっと僕やっ
誕生日なんて気を使ってくれたんですよね
し知らないけど
一発停に向かいます
f
うん
おっん
me
はいというわけでねー
今日日本に帰る日本人列がどうしてもご飯を食べたいって言うので来ました
皆さんどう思いますかこんな腐れ遊ぶ養老ですよ
何でイギリスに分に日本人と最後メっしょくんですか
グランデ居るぞと空のです
俺をやってくれるのかニキビしないからさ
英語花ぞ
プリスピンリング萎縮はナースかこの温度差を半端ないかいいん
4さえよ日本日本の16三振
だろでも俺も帰るも
でくださいは決勝美術
ビルドんで良いオファーする
なぜ本当にスチームあなたを帯びるのだというメーター食べると良い
どこ何カッ
あああん
ね会え掛けなようだスピスタのチェック see
ていますこと移ってもばやっぱりに通っ
サイバー
無双武将隊望むことにお会いすると
あれ区別は
goo
選挙ビール頼んだらて違いで2つもらいました
ん
これはれな英語力ですよ普段者ございます
21歳でしたねーついてもあるにはあっリバーしてうれしい
クリームいい
ただいま集まりません
札が白馬して割れてきまーすイェーイウーああっ
今日か若い欄でバレンタインデー new を飛ばさずですスタン最高よく
フィッシャーのチープです
あとが失う婦なんて呼べるって言って僕は
会ポスターポスターポスター分ビル全然のマン日付
んです
ああああああ
ただちょっと御婆のにいろいろと準備がいるからですか
ポテトでだねぇ
やっちゃうんです
ていた
だこれ
去年撮ってください後藤最近口悪いでこんな功名ってのは本当に何かなと思ったんだっ
そんな考えでござい
では日本が入ったら別アンサーの深くか言ってよ私は何なんじゃないか絶対タメ口で
いいよ
20年救命もらって
ああ大留ないん
alloy たそして
ブーブー言っはんっ
俺が結局一番偉いんが一番だよ知ってるわう
ています
コバエの中でます俺が1万円のフィール p でいっぱいでも酔うんで僕は本当に偉い
です
鼻水でるんだけど
いろいろ分おいてして持っているかお前もらってんじゃねーよね
v ラインかっこいいです
そういうちょっと仲良かったぐらいなんですけど
ことがたりまぁちょっと part b 型寝ましたあれやろう
出せ f
ほんのちょっとだけ仲良かったんですけどね
まあそんなに仲いいわけじゃないですけどね
ウンス帰れ帰れ
帰っ枯れ
日酔いで買え
あなたは入れませんそそんななんで
まヘンな顔だからお前ほらマーニーも使ってに入れるのにほら普通やんけ
ああやった総合
ps 25 e
一つばすレッスン
まあまあ今直訳しますとお前は乗れないということです
それ
が a 0
ゆるーいた巨星ですあー早くな裏ねー
それ
これが彼の最後の姿であった分
お前ら
今日はバレンタインデーでないけどバレンタインでたけどなぁ
俺は妹校指定
友達の
俺が同時にかかってるとかお前な言葉で言って見たことないよな
売れもやってくれたでしたああ
goo
チョコボ1個もらってないです
影響もありしたーー
ここ女じゃんってああ
俺今だ大丈夫伸びてないんだけど
誰もやってくるな
レッサーふーん
すーん
ん
dea
あっはあっはあっはあっやっ
えっええっ
アプリバレンタイン